now now it is what it is now can I tell
you a story about not lying I can show
you right now I can show you right now
on my phone but alright cuz I have it on
video but now listen don't sneeze okay
now I got a story about to sneeze I got
a story about fighting naked okay Jimmy
Burke who you know I know Jimmy Burke I
love Jimmy Jimmy Burke's I think it's
his
well his okay his his cousin no his his
nephew is a police officer Staten Island
they got a call when they get there
an intruder had come in and he was he
was well let me let me go they the woman
answers and she's in a row but she's
half-naked and he goes what's going on
it's just there's an intruder in our
house and my husband is fighting him
okay so they come running in and they
find the guy who's a big athletic guy
he's naked as the day is long and he's
got the guy in a [ __ ] guillotine
choke only who had broken in
yeah and they go let go and he goes I'm
not [ __ ] letting go not letting go
this guy because the guy had come in
yeah with a weapon apparently yeah and
Adam for yeah well so but he had him
there and he said let him go we got him
and they cuff him yeah and they and he's
holding on him and when they when he let
him go the guy was blue and dead was he
had so what that happened was they were
[ __ ] on the couch this guy who was a
rough what and what's what's Jimmy's
connection so his his his I believe his
nephew I'll check with him I think it's
his nephew through them through her
marriage his his nephew was one of the
cops on this case okay come in so they
were [ __ ] on the couch a dude breaks
thinking they're not in the house breaks
the [ __ ] window and jumps into the
living room
Jesus the guys mid mid mid stroke yeah
pulls out obviously with a hard-on you
may as well you may as well get the jump
on a [ __ ] Doberman Pinscher who's
heaven correct idiot correct because if
you're a real man like me yeah and and
diamond dick over here yeah diamond dick
that's you
Nikki thanks brother you have a dick is
a good day you don't [ __ ] wear it let
me tell you something yeah go ahead you
don't wear a cowboy hat the whole
[ __ ] podcast and not acknowledge that
your friend has a diamond hard day
thanks hey thanks brother
got it you're in my corner you always
have been I appreciate that hey you know
I got a piss hole too you know why I got
a diamond shape piss hole diamond shape
I got a rod I've got a diamond hard dick
I'm DDP diamond shape diamond shape
Issel yep and it's and it's not small
either you can you can pry stick that
index finger right right right I could
take a [ __ ] a sharpie yeah with the
lid on and now for an organic carrot
yeah one of those organic carrots not
too big but definitely not small yeah I
stink at it right in my dick or this
[ __ ] or this [ __ ] Johnsonville
bratwurst of a thumb that I have that
Italian found that sir being Italian
that Serbian Italian thought I if I grow
my nail a little long it's not Serbian I
hope I could shuck an oyster with that
thumb and I got a stick I got a piece of
leather in my help you let Josh come
here Brian and he'll [ __ ] shoot right
down rather even though join up yeah
we're both heterosexual dudes
sure we are that's well you're like more
your like your the to nose my standard
white male
that's right Italian I want to apologize
to my sister and her white male Ness
yeah and and and my supremacy and he'll
go anyway he cha he comes out the guy
maked yeah we got we went off on a
finger tangent you know you're all top
five of my [ __ ] favorite movie stars
best buddy you know I'm saying pound it
out thanks buddy
so diamond dick came at the guy and the
guy grabbed his legs and he put him in
the old guillotine no [ __ ] and [ __ ]
killed him naked and hard-on while his
girl watched him and then just was like
get him honey yeah then he slew a man
that's pretty romantic it is he stole a
man in his house and I want my question
is I wonder if they finished up after
that I was that stressed you gotta let
your stress go his cortisol levels are
sky-high yeah he just killed a man
he said you got he goes am I gonna be in
trouble yeah cop said what are you
talking about you're a hero got broken
really yeah oh that's great it's just
violence well yeah yeah that's true the
cops are like we'll handle
yeah normally in most situations there's
going to be some paperwork yellow now in
this case I want to say this if you are
having sex with your girl yeah and a guy
broke in yeah I think all due respect
yeah I love you think I believe I love
you to that because you're a sensitive
guy yeah you would piss and [ __ ]
okay fall to the ground and scream is
that true or no that is absolute you
fall on your back and piss straight up
in the air no and douse yourself with a
bunch of pain and then loose control
your mouth [ __ ] the floor yeah and then
scream mommy at the top of your lungs is
that what would happen in a manner of
speaking Brian that is what would happen
and I'll tell you why no shame in that
is number one as soon as I hear that as
soon as I hear someone fumbling with my
door my gal who would be on top of me at
this place on top of you she'd be on top
of me because I'd be asleep and with a
rock hard day yeah and then she'd just
get on and then I'd say I'd say maybe I
gotta handle some business and then
she'd roll off by the way my girls
little dog sleeps under the bed look out
when they're over and and she's a cute
little first mistake we're having a
little dog get a bigger dog yet but I'm
saying you know I got to protect them
both oh my adorable little dog yeah so I
would go bed I got some I got some
business to handle yeah a little the
puja yeah I go
stay back Ronnie yep and then I then I
would 100% piss up in a fountain while
the guys still trying to get the door
open
into my own muck the reason for this
don't worry about it Sam my urine
contains so much testosterone it's gonna
get me [ __ ] bull snortin mad so you
soon as I drink your own urine yes and a
lot of it would go up my nose now you
know your test is [ __ ] Jack my test
is Jack yes now the thing you said
wasn't gonna [ __ ] myself
yeah well if I have time to get over to
the toilet I will if not you know I
probably just maybe grab the closest
pair of jeans or and would you sit in
your hand cowboy hats that I have if I
add to I and would you throw it in would
you would you have two handfuls to
fiddle handfuls of sass oh [ __ ] no and
then when the guy comes in would you box
his ears with it that's not the regime
sighs the reason that I'm [ __ ] is to
it's like when a boxer a fighter makes
weight my [ __ ] as you know because
you're a good friend of mine weighs
anywhere from 20 to 35 pounds
that's one of my shits so and I like to
eat late at night yeah when I eat late
at night I eat a lot okay so I take one
of those massive dumps yep around 25
pounds [ __ ] yeah now a marrow dynamic
yeah it's time to work out you wouldn't
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] like right in front of
the door so when the guy walks in he
goes goddamn I got jet net boom you
[ __ ] Ryan eyes those are parlor
tricks I wanna [ __ ] mom I wanna
[ __ ] honest one-on-one with this man
okay the last thing you said was what
ice cream mommy yes I would I'd say this
is for my mother which is what I say
before I kill every man though and that
number is in the dozens so a lot of men
with your hands are with with that's two
piles of [ __ ] here again I have had some
dirty Dookie on my digits when it's time
to [ __ ] battle down with the dude I
gotta reach up into my hole to get some
out if I'm eating a lot of meat okay so
you reason again that I lose weight and
lose the weight when I [ __ ] is to make
weight for a fair fight okay I'll get
down from ooh I don't know about right
now how much would you say that I win
be honest and be honest and don't be
insulting how much do I'm not gonna be
insulting all right I mean if I have
lost some weight with your clothes on
huh with your clothes on no make it a
[ __ ] and I will gear down right here
with my bird hanging out for it I don't
know I'm guessing weight dude I'm six
foot three all right so then so five no
are you serious no you look you're
actually you're look all right you're
looking at you're looking at 300 I'm
gonna give you 300
that's that would have been fair in the
past I've been working out a lot with
our boy Nick yep Brian right my boy the
trainer to me Nick flour
yeah Nick flour he's the [ __ ] but no
more class he is Ryan and I don't like
to you know choose our times when we
work that's true he's overdosed gym yeah
he's a [ __ ] frenzy right [ __ ] I
said there's a lot of gyms on the street
he goes he goes yeah and you can step
into any number of them if you
learn nothing he's the best Nick is the
best he's the best trainer I've ever had
if I always [ __ ] phenomenal because he
knows movement so well
yeah and I'll do something he goes Wow
okay very mediocre you wanted you want
to do it right or you got this though
you would you got this I'll start doing
my own thing because all you got this
it's okay my feet me up yesterday
I'm Soros [ __ ] right now really we went
deadlift and bench oh wow yeah he I had
my shoulders all [ __ ] up and I thought
it was tendinitis he said you move very
well he said I move he said you move
very well your movement is it great he
said how about that well I'm an athlete
breath and then he had me rolling on a
[ __ ] one of those little rollers on
my lap and my shoulder oh it was amazing
he understands the the thing at the same
thing to me yesterday I had to lose some
weight for a show and they said we want
you to loot the answer the question by
the way before I kill anybody and when I
make weight is a lean 205 pounds so
anyway um but 200 to move on from there
huh 205 I'm around to I I go anywhere
from 190 to tool that's so anyway um so
anyway so anyway moving heavier this so
anyway that make you like call me thirty
pounds
so anyway okay so anyways right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]